[Applause]
[Music]
israel does not have the world's biggest
army but it is the most effective
think about it we are talking about a
country with less than nine
million inhabitants nonetheless they
have won wars against countries
10 times bigger for example during the
six days war israel confronted a
coalition that included
egypt syria and jordan
[Music]
all of these countries put together
summed up to more than 130 million
people
and they sent over 240 000
soldiers twice as many as the israeli
army did in other words
no one would expect a victory for israel
but history was rather different
in just six days the israeli defense
forces also known as idf
wiped out their enemies and yes i know
what you're going to say
now the israelis have the best
technology and weaponry
right well that is true now but it
wasn't back then for instance in 1973
during the yom kippur war
israel's weapons were as modern as those
of their main rivals syria
[Music]
in fact the idf had some combat jets
manufactured in the 1950s
the famous a4 skyhawk however the
syrians they had state-of-the-art
anti-aircraft missiles they were given
to the soviets just five years before
and who won that war yeah it was israel
all right all right so i can hear some
of you saying now i'll come on time but
israel has the sport of america that's a
really big help
and yes at this point you are right
israel is the country that receives the
most help from uncle sam
but do you know of any other country who
buys the best weaponry
from america well that would be saudi
arabia the saudis have an army as big
and as modern as the israeli one but if
you've been subscribed to visualpolitik
for a while you already know that the
big failure of the saudi army was
fighting guerrilla warriors
namely those houthi rebels from yemen in
other words neither the technology nor
the american support are enough to
explain
why the israeli army is such a fearful
one
so the question of the day is why is the
israeli army so powerful
what are the key elements explaining
such military success
well today we are going to tell you the
five key facts that
explain this
[Music]
fast decision making every army is based
on hierarchy and authority
right well some of them they're more
flexible than others
in this other video we explained how the
saudi army has a bigger sense of
hierarchy and the officials don't have
much
power to make their own decisions the
same goes with other arabic countries
like syria
or egypt so here is an example imagine a
syrian unit defending a position
let's say their headquarters have been
destroyed before the soldiers in the
frontline are aware of it
if they have to follow the normal
procedure they will have to wait until
someone gives them an order during this
time
they don't know if they should retreat
strike back or coordinate with other
military units
alright so now you might be wondering
well why are arab armies so
centralized now don't forget that most
of these countries are dictatorships or
absolute monarchies
if you are a tyrant you want your army
to be under control in order to
micromanage
every little decision in order to
prevent a coup d'etat
the israeli army is way different from
that let's
look back to our previous example in
this case the israeli commander on the
front line
wouldn't need to wait for orders he has
a degree of his own decision-making
power so he can react immediately and
seize opportunities
in fact this is pretty normal in almost
all western armies the big planning is
centralized but the execution is
decentralized this way the organization
is more flexible and can react more
quickly
but unlike the western countries israel
has something unique in their culture
we are talking about a pretty unknown
fact about this country yet it
is a very very important one israel is
the least hierarchical country on the
planet
and you can feel this in every aspect of
their culture
inside of an israeli company it's pretty
normal for an average worker to have a
discussion with his boss
debates are a common thing and there is
a pretty small sense of authority
actually in the 1970s a dutch
anthropologist named geard hofstedder
studied the power relationships in
different countries over the course of
six years
he surveyed ibm workers in different
offices around the globe this is how the
power distance index was born and among
all those countries
israel has the lowest power distance
while the arab countries like egypt or
saudi arabia
rank among the highest in other words
israeli citizens are educated in
flexibility more than any other nation
internal cohesion in israel military
service is mandatory for every citizen
regardless of their social condition or
their gender both men and women rich and
poor
start from the very bottom
[Music]
well actually this is not entirely true
because the ultra-orthodox jews don't
need to do military service and neither
does israel's palestinian population
but the rest of israel's citizens must
serve in the military and
fall into a meritocratic scheme this
means everyone must follow
the same rules in order to be promoted
and this
is not as common as you might think for
instance during world war ii the
aristocrats who joined the british army
started with higher positions than the
peasants and the working class
[Music]
and of course such elitism it tends to
destroy an army's morale and make it
harder for it to function for example
the saudi army consists of both civil
servants
and members of the royal family
and hierarchy matters a lot the son of a
saudi prince will never be a soldier
and as you can imagine this classist
structure has negative consequences
combat morale in the year 1973 israel
fought the egyptian and the syrian army
at the same time
as we said at the beginning back then
israel was not the technological
powerhouse that it is today
syrians had those anti-aircraft guns the
s-200s that we mentioned before
and during the first days those
anti-aircraft missiles destroyed
a lot of israeli combat jets israel they
had to retreat
nonetheless uncle sam was here to help
the white house sent a package of
weapons so they could neutralize the
s200s and the radars
things like flares that could confuse
the smart missiles that were guided by
temperature
this way the israeli struck back and in
a short amount of time they finished off
the syrian defenses
and well guess what happened next well a
lot of those arab soldiers scared of
being wiped out from the air
well they defected
if you look at the picture on the screen
you will see seven syrian tanks
they are not moving but not one of them
is destroyed
[Music]
well it means that the soldiers that
were inside of those tanks they decided
to run away
defection is a common problem when
morale is low
and this is a common problem for arab
armies
20 syrian troops defect to southern
turkish province of hate
think about it if you are an israeli
soldier or an american one
you know you must be loyal to your
country but arab soldiers have too many
ethnic
national and religious identities
imagine you are a syrian soldier and at
the same time you are a kurd
or you belong to the muslim brotherhood
both groups are chased by the syrian
government
so well who are you loyal to of course
the army pays your bills but when your
life is a risk and everything is lost
what's more important your salary or
your life
in other words no matter your wealth and
your technology if your soldiers are not
strongly motivated
you've already lost and the israelis
they know that better than anyone
[Music]
human capital all tanks place their
engines on the back side
but why is this because usually the
rockets sit on the front side
and you want your tank to keep working
even after being hit
this is why all the models from the
german leopards to the russian t-90s
keep their engines in the back
nonetheless the israeli army doesn't
value the vehicle as much as their
soldiers
this is why the israeli macava is the
only one of its kind that has the
engines in the front
this way a rocket will destroy the tank
but it will protect the soldiers putting
aside the ethics
israel has a really small population
this means that they can't allow
themselves
to lose too many soldiers this is why
they receive much more intense training
with real bullets
and better equipment and don't forget
that this is the country where krav maga
one of the most advanced martial arts
was born
you can also see this human capital
doctrine reflected in their intelligence
service the mossad
it is considered one of the best in the
entire world
[Music]
and if one day you happen to travel to
israel you should know that they will
take your phone number and other data
because they know information is power
[Music]
but all right all right i know what you
want to hear now you came to this video
because you wanted to hear about
state-of-the-art weaponry right
well here you have it
made in israel during the 1980s the
israeli government wanted a secret
weapon
a weapon no one had ever heard of until
recently so they met a local
manufacturer
a company called raphael to design a
very special vehicle
the so-called pera
this is a vehicle that looks like a tank
but in fact is a tank hunter weapon
with a big rocket launcher if you know
about weapons you know there's a big
difference
tank weaponry has to reach a distance of
between two and four kilometers
peri-rockets can travel a distance of
30.
so imagine the situation the enemies
would take satellite pictures to see the
israeli weaponry
and they would see a lot of normal tanks
based on this they would plan their
strategy but then
surprise surprise those tanks are not
tanks but in fact
something with a much much bigger reach
for decades this pera was one of the
most mysterious weapons of the israeli
army
and their main strength was that no one
knew anything about them so now the
question is
how come israel makes its own secret
weapons and other countries don't
well the answer is that in israel there
are a lot of rocket science companies
that give it a world-class defense
industry so a while ago we did a video
about
israeli startups well in the 1980s the
israeli government created a special
program which was called yosma
this program consisted of 10 hedge funds
with both private and
government money in them those funds
helped to create a lot of tech companies
and you know what the favorite industry
for those brand new startups was
well of course it was the military
industry at the end of the day the
army was a rich and reliable client all
of a sudden
dozens of weapon manufacturers were born
companies that created customized
products
that met the exact needs of the israeli
army at every moment
from the iron dome defense system to the
merkava tanks
or the parade we mentioned before so now
you might be wondering what happened in
the other countries well let's first
consider saudi arabia as you know the
saudi economy has got a problem
it relies heavily on the oil industry of
course thanks to the dinosaur jews the
saudis have become
rich and they can pay for the third
biggest army in the world
only surpassed by china and america
but expensive is not a synonym for good
the saudi army buys their tanks from the
usa
and those are customized for the needs
of the american army
besides that makes it harder to have a
secret weapon because everyone knows
what you bought on the international
market
alright so i probably know what you're
thinking now it seems that we're really
talking up the israelis right
but do make no mistake the israeli army
certainly has its weak points
in fact there is an organization that
could make their life even harder
but that's something we're going to talk
about in another video
[Music]
now the question for you is who do you
think can defeat the israeli army and
what do you think their main weak points
are
well please leave your answers in the
comments section below
meanwhile please visit our friends at
the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
are not mine
also do not forget that we publish brand
new videos every single week so do not
forget to subscribe and you won't miss a
single post
and if you like this video please do
give it a thumbs up and as always
i'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there